Dann kommen wir eigentlich eh schon zu den Listen.
Und Listen sind auch eigentlich, also das haben wir, glaube ich,
eh gestern schon ein bisschen durchgemacht mit den Strings.
Also es ist sehr ähnlich zu den Strings.
Listen sind nur noch praktisch noch viel stärker.
Praktisch, wir können da nicht nur einzelne Characters speichern,
wie wir hier haben, sondern wir können da wirklich ganze Elemente speichern.
Und wir können diese auf diese Elemente zugreifen und verändern.
Und genau, also das Wichtigste mal zuerst,
wir haben praktisch am Anfang diese eckigen Klammern.
Also das definiert ein Listen-Typ.
Das könnt ihr auch mal kurz probieren, also das ist einfach...
Es sollte da auch bei den variablen Benennungen praktisch vermeiden,
dass ihr List, das Keyword List zum Beispiel verwendet.
Also List ist nämlich schon eigentlich vergeben als Keyword,
weil ihr praktisch damit zum Beispiel auch eine Liste definieren könnt.
Aber ihr könnt ruhig das deutsche Wort verwenden, zum Beispiel Liste.
Und das hier wird zum Beispiel eine leere Liste.
Diese speziellen Keywords werden euch normalerweise auch bewischt,
das Studio Code und so eigentlich auch schon markiert, andersfarbig.
Also da kommt ihr dann eigentlich sehr schnell drauf,
dass okay, dieses Keyword scheint benutzt zu sein.
So viel ergibt es da eigentlich eh nicht.
Die wichtigsten sind eh List, Set und Doppel.
Die sind schon vordefiniert.
Weil ihr praktisch nicht nur mit diesen eckigen Klammern,
sondern auch eben immer mit diesen Keyword und Klammer auf Klammer zu,
das Gleiche machen könnt.
Also das hier sind keine Listen, das sind andere Sachen,
da kommen wir auch dazu.
Sie sind sehr ähnlich zu Listen, aber keine Listen.
Genau, steht eigentlich hier schon oben, das ist ja wie mit einer leeren Liste definiert.
Und es ist eigentlich ziemlich ähnlich über Strings,
praktisch wie greift man auf diese Elemente in einer Liste dann zu.
Ganz einfach, wir verwenden wieder diesen Index.
Das heißt praktisch, ich habe hier meine Liste definiert,
schrabe ich noch eine Eins rein.
Wenn ich da jetzt auf diese Eins zugreifen will, also auf das erste Element unserer Liste.
Was schrabe ich da rein?
Null, genau, weil die komischen Informatik kann mit Null beginnen mit Zählen.
Das Gleiche auch, wie bei den Strings wieder,
praktisch ein negativer Index fängt von hinten an zu zählen,
das heißt minus 1 gibt uns das letzte Element.
Speziell für Listen ist jetzt, dass wir die Sachen bearbeiten können,
also eigentlich auch wie bei Strings, aber man kann dann praktisch einfach sagen,
okay, ich will das erste Element hier verändern, also mal hier einfach,
hier in diesem Fall Colors an der Stelle Null, also an der ersten Stelle,
habe ich jetzt mal zugewiesen auf Gray.
Ich kann das aber auch dann später im Code dann einfach sagen,
ja, ich will da gar nicht Gray mit E schreiben, sondern anders.
Und kann ich einfach später sagen, ja, ich will das mit A schreiben
und dann wird dieses Element überschrieben.
Das heißt, da steht da nicht mal Gray drin, mit E, sondern Gray mit A
und das wird dann auch so gespeichert, also im Fortlaufen des Programms.
Ihr könnt dann natürlich auch neue Elemente hinzufügen,
das ist eben mit Append, wenn ihr an einer sehr speziellen Stelle der Liste
irgendwo ein Element hinzufügen wollt, dann müsst ihr das mit Insert machen
und mit dem Index, wo ihr an welcher Stelle das Element in der Liste haben wollt,
das ist auch wieder praktisch genau wie hier auch, fängt wieder mit Null an.
Gibt es da so Fragen?
Okay, jetzt kann man natürlich diese hinzugefügten Elemente auch wieder löschen,
man kann auch natürlich Elemente löschen, die schon vordefiniert waren,
also es ist nicht so, dass man nur Elemente löschen kann, die nur hinzugefügt worden sind.
Genau, man kann das mit Dell machen, das sollte man aber eher bisschen vermeiden,
besser ist das Pop, weil das dann wirklich das Element dann einfach rauslöscht
und weiß gar nicht, wie das ist, muss ich kurz nachschauen.
Machen wir da mal eine Liste.
Die einzelnen Elemente sind kommergetrennt, zur besseren Lesbarkeit könnt ihr da auch einfach Leerzeichen immer dazu machen,
die sind aber nicht verpflichtend.
Ich glaube für den Coding-Standard schon, also besser Leerzeichen verwenden.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt diese Liste hier auch brinden würde, dann haben wir das so.
Und jetzt lösch ich da ein Element, machen wir gleich das erste,
schauen wir mal, was rauskommt.
Okay, dann wird es auch wirklich gelöscht.
Sag mal, Pop ist in dem Fall hilfreich, wenn ihr das Element noch verwenden wollt,
das heißt, wenn ich da Liste.pop...
Normalerweise, wenn man nur Pop aufruft, dann wird da nämlich, ich mach das so, das letzte Element gelöscht.
Und ihr könnt das praktisch dann noch verwenden, das heißt ihr könnt dieses Pop hier,
da bekommt ihr auch wirklich, also das ist wie, ich drücke die Liste und dann popt das letzte Element raus
und jetzt habe ich das Element und kann damit noch was anfangen.
Der Lied ist es einfach weg, also bei, mit dem Dell Keyword ist es futsch und weg ist die Post.
Da ist er wirklich, also da kann ich noch machen, X ist gleich Pop.
Da kann ich das einfach hier daneben noch rausbrinden.
Das heißt praktisch, ich habe jetzt so mal Pop aufgerufen, das heißt, die zwei Elemente sind da rausgepoppt.
Ich habe bei X das erste mal Pop aufgerufen, da wird praktisch dann das Dreier herausgedrückt
und das wird dann hier in diese Variable X gespeichert.
Dann rufe ich nochmal Pop auf, hier verwende ich es nicht weiter, außer für das Print.
Das heißt, die Liste ist nur noch mit einem Element übrig, weil wir jetzt zwei mal Pop aufgerufen haben
und in X steht drei drin.
Ist das soweit verständlich oder gibt es dazu Fragen?
Pop und dann gibt es auch noch Remove und Remove ist deshalb hilfreich.
Also Delete, wenn wir das anschauen, dann gehen wir den speziellen Index an,
aber sagen wir mal, wir wissen jetzt nicht den Index, wir wollen aber einfach einen Kanon hier in diesem Fall Gray löschen,
weil wir uns die Gefahr über auf die Nerven geht, dann können wir das mit Remove machen.
Das heißt, Colors hat danach kein Element mit Gray mehr drin.
Und wie bei Strings können wir auch wieder die Länge von Listen erfahren, indem wir dieses Land Keyword hier verwenden.
Praktisch, das kommt von Länge und damit können wir praktisch herausfinden, wie lang unser Liste ist,
also wie viele Elemente wir wirklich drin haben.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch wieder Index Errors, praktisch, wenn wir da wieder auf einen ungültigen Index zugreifen in Analyster,
dann wird Beifen sehr unhappy sein und uns sagen, na, da kannst du nicht zugreifen, das existiert gar nicht,
dann kommt so ein Index Error raus. Also falls ihr so ein Index Error sieht, also nicht indent Error, sondern ein Index Error,
dann wisst ihr, okay, ich habe auf ein Element in der Liste zugegriffen, das ist nicht existierab,
praktisch auf eine Index zugegriffen, der außerhalb der Länge unserer Liste ist.
Genau.
Und sonst eben, wenn ihr das letzte Element haben wollt, wieder mit Minus 1.
Und da gibt es auch wieder das gleiche wie bei Stringslicing, das haben wir durchgemacht.
Also man kann bei den Listen auch wieder das gleiche Slicing Verfahren verwenden, das heißt, man kann ja auch wieder hergehen.
Und
kann ich machen, L von 0 bis 2,
dann bekomme ich raus, also
1, 2. Also das funktioniert natürlich auch wieder.
Genau, das sieht so.
Genau, das habe ich jetzt gerade erinnert.
Es sollte eh identisch sein wie bei Stringslicing.
Genau, und wie gesagt, ein Stringslicing ist eh eigentlich nichts anderes als eine Liste mit einzelnen Buchstaben drin.
Genau, dann haben wir nochmal dieses in und not in.
Nein, das haben wir gar nicht gehabt, nein, wir haben das is gehabt, sorry, selber verwirrt.
Und das in ermöglicht uns rauszufinden, ob ein Element in der Liste ist oder nicht.
Und das ist natürlich sehr praktisch, wenn wir das Ganze mit einem if kombinieren.
Das heißt, wir haben hier unser Liste L,
wenn ich das sage if 1 in L,
L, dann mache ich da was.
Das heißt, ich kann sehr schnell rausfinden, ob ein Element in meiner Liste ist oder nicht.
Ich kann das natürlich das umgekehrt auch machen mit not in, das ist praktisch einfach die Verneinung davon.
Ein sehr starkes Instrument.
Gestern habe ich auch kurz erwähnt bei den Strings zum Beispiel das Feind.
Das gibt es natürlich auch bei Listen, wenn man wirklich den Index haben will.
Da gibt es also sehr ähnliche Operatoren.
Gibt es dazu Fragen?
Was der Befehllist hier bringt, größtenteils einfach nur für die Lesbarkeit des Codes.
Es gibt dann nämlich noch speziellere Arten, wie man mit Listen eigentlich nicht,
aber es ist einfach für die Lesbarkeit.
Also dann weiß ich, okay, das ist ein List.
Aber es ist eigentlich identisch wie zu den Eckigen Klammern.
Und ihr könnt auch einfach direkt eckige Klammer verwenden, also ihr müsst ja nicht List, Klammer aufwenden.
Ja.
Na ja, du kannst glaube mit List nur Lehrer-Listen definieren.
Das ist eben, ja, das ist nur, sagen wir zum Beispiel am Anfang des Programms habe ich
eine Variable-Liste 3, die ich unbedingt schon davor definieren will als Lehrer-Liste.
Dann kann ich das eben dieses Keyword hier verwenden, dieses List Keyword.
Dann kann ich natürlich auch einfach den Klammer nehmen.
Also dieses Keyword ist eher relativ wenig im Gebrauch, normalerweise.
Was ganz cool ist, ist auch, man kann die Listen auch sortieren.
Das heißt, wir haben da zwei Möglichkeiten, wir haben einmal das Punkt Sort.
Das kann ich auch kurz mal kurz zeigen.
Warte, bevor ich das mache.
Praktisch, wir haben hier einmal das Punkt Sort.
Das heißt, das hier ist eine Liste.
Und dann kann ich da Punkt Sort aufrufen.
Und dann wird mir, dann sortiert mir bei diese Liste.
Das heißt praktisch alle Elemente.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier 3, 2, 1 geschrieben hätte, dann würde die sortiert nach 1, 2, 3.
Das Gleiche ist auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel das Drinks drin habe, dann werde die eben nach Anfangsbuchstaben sortiert.
Das heißt ABC.
Man kann das natürlich auch reversen.
Also man kann da auch einfach dann noch angeben, ich will hier reverse das Ganze machen.
Oder eben auch so machen.
Aber das hier ist ein bisschen spezielleres Keyword, das ist jetzt, das kommen wir auch gleich dazu.
Das hier ist ein eigenständiges Statement.
Das heißt, ich schreibe da nicht nochmal Colors, ist gleich Colors.sort,
sondern ich schreibe nur Colors.sort und dann ist meine Colors Liste sortiert.
Wenn ich aber Colors unsortiert haben möchte, also weil ich die später noch so unsortiert praktisch brauche,
dann kann ich mir eine neue Liste machen mit diesem sorted Keyword.
Das heißt, praktisch schreibe sorted, klamm auf, halte meine unsortierte Liste rein
und dann gibt mir dieses sorted Keyword eine sortierte Liste, aber das ist eine neue Liste zurück.
Das Ganze kann man natürlich auch mit Strings machen, weil das natürlich auch eine Liste ist.
Und eben auch eine Liste von Strings.
Wichtig ist da die Großschreibung, also ein großes A ist nicht das gleiche wie ein kleines A.
Das kann man auch kurz herzeigen.
Ich glaube, das hat da kein sort Keyword.
Da können wir nur sorted verwenden.
Und die hier seht, werden alle Großbuchstaben von den Kleinbuchstaben sortiert.
Also es ist ein bisschen eine Eigenheit, das hat damit zu tun, dass man dieses A zum Beispiel in ein Integer-Wert umwandeln kann auf zwei Umwege.
Das heißt, man kann da z.B. Klapp C, H, R, S, oder auch nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das ist.
Okay, das ist praktisch das Umgekehrte.
Das heißt, wenn ich hier 9.7 rein schreibe, dann bekomme ich das.
Genau, also die haben intern alle einen Wert.
Hier im diesem Fall das kleine A hat den Wert 97.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das große A für einen Wert hat.
Okay, 65 hat das.
Also das große A hat den Wert 65 und das kleine A hat den Wert 97.
Und deshalb werden die auch so sortiert.
Das kann man in einer, zum Beispiel in einer ASCII Tabelle nachschauen.
Ich kann das auch kurz zeigen.
Das schaut dann so aus.
Praktisch hier, in diesem Fall haben wir praktisch unseren Dezimalwert hier
und dann unseren Charakter, also unseren einzelnen Charakter,
unser einzelnen Schriftzeichen hier.
Und wie ihr hier seht, ist hier das große A mit 65
und dann geht das darunter.
Und dann kommen wir noch ein paar Sonderzeichen
und dann bei 97 startet das kleine Alphabet,
bis Z was bei 122 endet.
Und das ist intern, was Beifen verwendet,
um praktisch den Buchstammel einen Wert zu geben.
Genau, da vielleicht noch kurz hier zum Sorten.
Da gibt es den Reverse-Parameter, den ihr auf True setzen könnt.
Das ist dann praktisch eine spezielle Option für diese Funktion hier
und ich sage dann, okay, wir wollen das Ganze eigentlich umgekehrt sortiert haben.
Dann sortiert ihr das uns umgekehrt.
Genau so werden die einfach dann reversed.
Das ist nicht das gleiche wie sort.
In diesem Fall natürlich ist es das gleiche wie sort reversed,
aber wenn wir dann noch hat dritt, das sind Zufügen.
B, starten wir es mit B.
Also in diesem Fall hat man hier A, B, J am Anfang des Strings
und natürlich wenn wir da noch einen drin haben, der zum Beispiel mit zwei As beginnt,
dann wird der noch vor dem anderen String mit einem A geschrieben,
weil der praktisch hier dann an zweiter Stelle ein B hat.
Jetzt, wenn wir das reversen,
dann haben wir praktisch hier umgekehrt sortiert.
Also hier haben wir dann das AA ganz zum Schluss und das J hier am Anfang,
aber wenn wir hier einfach nur reverse reinschreiben,
dann dreht er uns einfach die Liste um.
Das heißt, wir haben hier zwar das AA an der Anfang,
aber das AB ist hier noch immer ganz zum Schluss.
Aber ich habe euch da nicht zu viel verwirrt, ist das verständlich?
Gibt es da Fragen?
Was?
Dann haben wir das auch.
Genau, dann gibt es ja noch spezielle Art von Listen.
Na stimmt, das ist eigentlich keine Liste,
das ist eigentlich eine Zahlensequenz
und das nennt sich eigentlich einen Generator.
Und das können wir mit Range machen, also mit diesem Range Keyword
und das ist sehr praktisch, wenn wir jetzt einfach eine schnelle
Zahlensequenz brauchen, von 0 bis 100,
dann können wir einfach Range 101 reinschreiben,
weil praktisch das letzte,
also diese Zahl ist exklusiv,
das heißt, wir haben hier nur 0 bis 3,
aber wie ihr seht, sind das ja vier Elemente.
Da kann man natürlich auch noch vieles anderes machen,
zum Beispiel eben den Start-Abpunkt definieren,
also wenn ich nicht bei 0 starten will,
sondern bei 1, dann kann ich da eben noch 1 davor schreiben,
beistrigt und dann das Ende.
Und ich kann auch,
die Schrittweise angeben,
das heißt praktisch,
hier in diesem Fall
gehen wir mal in drei Schritten weiter.
Wir starten bei 1,
dann 3 weiter, 4,
dann nochmal 3 weiter, 7
und dann haben wir,
wenn wir da nochmal 3 weiter gehen,
dann wäre das ja 10,
aber 10 ist exklusiv,
weil es ist nicht mehr enthalten.
Und man kann diese Zahlensequenzen einfach umwandeln
mit diesem List keyword,
also für das ist es eigentlich
größtenteils eben,
fürs Casting wird es verwendet.
Und das coole mit den Listen ist auch,
sagen wir mal, wir definieren es,
da haben wir eine Liste von 10,
das ist die Liste,
die Liste von 0 bis 2,
also 0, 1, 2,
dann können wir da eben
das Minimum herausfinden
mit diesem Min keyword,
das heißt,
da kriegen wir dann 0 raus,
wenn wir da Max reingeben,
also Max und die Liste,
dann kriegen wir 2 raus.
Wir können auch die Summe machen,
das heißt,
alle Elemente werden aufsummiert,
das geht dann natürlich
nur gescheit mit integer oder float,
mit string,
das ist eine gute Frage,
ob man strings aufsummieren kann,
müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Man sagt ja,
weil er hier
Summe startet
mit einem 0 integer,
also definiert sich
intern einfach einen Counter
mit 0,
oder halt
einen Summen-Counter,
das heißt,
wenn man die Summen-Counter
aufsummiert,
dann kann man die Summen-Counter
aufsummieren,
um die Summen-Counter
und dann versucht er hier
das erste Objekt zu addieren,
aber das ist hier in diesem Fall
ein string,
und wie wir ja wissen,
kann man strings mit integers nicht addieren,
außer sie werden gecastet,
das heißt,
hier gibt es ein Fehler.
Und da kann man zum Beispiel auch ganz simpel
dann den Durchschnittwert
ausrechnen und zum Beispiel
wenn wir 0, 1, 2 haben,
dann addiert es praktisch Summe und das auf,
das wäre dann praktisch 0 plus 1 plus 2,
in diesem Fall 3,
durch die Länge,
die Länge der Liste ist auch 3,
3 dividiert auch 3,
der Durchschnitt ist 1.